MALE SPEAKER: OK,
hi, everyone.
Today, I'm going to talk about
the Spatial Data Access Tool,
enable visualization and access
of geospatial data
using OGC services
and Google Earth.
[INAUDIBLE], I'm a postdoctoral
researcher
associate from Oak Ridge
National Lab.
And I'm working together with
[INAUDIBLE], Bob, Bruce, and
Tammy on this work.
Before I start, let me ask
a couple of questions.
Do you spend quite some time on
finding the data that can
be used in your research using
Google or some other tools?
If you find some data, do you
want to see the data, instead
of just the reading some
words about it?
If the data is actually what you
need, do you want to get
the data in a form that can be
used quickly and directly in
your research with only
minimum processing?
The Spatial Data Access Tool I'm
going to introduce today
will help you to solve
those problems.
It makes it easier for you to
find, visualize, and access
biogeochemical and ecological
data that is useful in
environmental research.
This work is funded by ORNL DAAC
and the MAST-DC projects.
Let me first give a
brief introduction
to those two projects.
The ORNL DAAC, the Oak Ridge
National Laboratory
Distributed Active Archive
Center, is a NASA-sponsored
source for biogeochemical and
ecological data and models
useful in environmental
research.
It is a crucial link for the
validation of biogeochemical
inferences from remotely
sensed data.
The data kept in the ORNL DAAC
mainly fall into three
categories, the field campaign
data, land validation data,
and the related regional
and global data.
There are over 800 data sets and
about 220,000 data files.
And the total volume is
about 1.1 terabytes.
The data files are stored in
various formats, including
ASCII, binary, metacdf,
and the [INAUDIBLE].
The Modeling and Synthesis
Thematic Data Center, the
MAST-DC, provides data
management support for the
North American Carbon
Program project.
Its goal is to provide data in
the formats, resolutions, and
the projections based on
users' requirements.
There are many carbon
cycling models
involved in the NACP project.
So the data archived in MAST-DC
includes model inputs
and outputs data.
It also includes some
observations data like forest
and crop inventory,
tower fluxes.
There's some other related
data like climate and
[INAUDIBLE] data archived.
Data centers is, especially
for those handling Earth
science data, are facing
challenges.
The rapidly increasing archiving
rate of geospatial
data is only one issue.
A bigger one is that
geospatial data is
heterogeneous in many aspects,
including data format and
metadata standard.
The rapidly growing user
community is another challenge.
Users are getting more
requirements on
the data they need.
And they expect more customized
the data than just
the raw data.
And nowadays, different data
centers are using different
mechanisms to publish and
deliver data to users.
And this introduces extra
burdens to users if they need
to access data from
multiple centers.
So this situation is getting
more critical.
With the Earth science,
researchers are getting more
complex and expanding across
more disciplines.
Data users need to find and
visualize data efficiently.
They need to access diverse data
in ready-for-use formats
and also in a standard way.
So the data centers need to take
new solutions to solve
those problems and certify
the data users.
The ORNL DAAC and the MAST-DC
have tapped into the benefits
offered by Open Geospatial
Consortium standards,
Web-enabled GIS tools, and the
Virtual Globe technology to
accomplish this goal.
So what is OGC?
OGC is special name for Open
Geospatial Consortium.
It is nonprofit, international,
voluntary
consensus standards organization
that is leading
to the development of standards
for geospatial and
location-based services.
The OGC standards cover almost
all aspects of geospatial
information, including the
representation, management,
processing, and application.
The OGC standards we are using,
the WMS and WCS, fall
into the category of geospatial
information
management.
The OGC Web Coverage Service,
WCS, defines a standard
interface that enables
customizable access to
geospatial coverage data.
A coverage means a phenomenon
that covers a geographic area,
such as satellite images
and the digital
elevation model data.
The OGC Web Map Service, the
WMS, defines a standard
interface that enables the
visualization of geospatial
data and this including both
the coverage and features.
This standardization of the data
visualization and access
promotes the geospatial
information interoperability,
which benefits both the data
centers and the data users.
Based on MapServer, we developed
and deployed the OGC
WCS and WMS servers.
The ORNL WCS server is
compatible with OGC WCS
standard version 1.0.0.
It provides the features for
customized geospatial coverage
data access, like spatial,
temporal, [? fan ?]
subsetting, reprojection,
resampling, and reformatting.
Popular data formats are
supported, including GeoTIF,
ARC/Infor, ASCII [INAUDIBLE],
netCDF, and
ITF and IRDIS Imagine.
The ORNL WMS server is
compatible with OGC WMS
standard version 1.1.1 besides
those features
provided in WCS server.
It also supports both automatic
and the manual color
scheme definition.
It can render images in PNG,
JPEG, and GIF formats.
The ORNL WCS and WMS servers are
mainly machine oriented.
In order to bring the benefits
of those servers to the end
users, we developed the Spatial
Data Access Tool.
And the URL is listed here.
The SDAT tool is a Web
application that enable users
to find, visualize, and access
geospatial data in user
specified temporal, spatial,
expanded resolution, format,
and projection.
It provides a WMS-driven
interactive map widget for
data visualization and
WCS-based options for
customizable data access.
Within Spatial Data Access
Tool, geospatial data is
organized in two levels, the
data set level and the data
file level.
As of today, there are 65 data
sets available through the
ORNL OGC servers and the Spatial
Data Access Tool.
Those data sets fall into a
couple of major categories,
including land cover,
elevation, soil,
climate, and ecoregion.
The main page of the Spatial
Data Access Tool, as shown on
the left image, provides a list
of all the available data
sets, their preview images, a
keyword search box, and the
links to metadata pages and KMZ
files, which I will talk
about later.
Following the links provided
from the main page, users can
get to another page listing all
the files contained in the
specific data set along with
some brief file level metadata
information.
The file-level interface
provides rich file-level
metadata information on the top
of the page, for example,
the projection definition in
OGC, a well-known text format.
In the middle of this page
is an OpenLayers-based
interactive map widget.
Within this map widget, users
can pan, zoom in, or zoom out
on the map.
It also supports on the
fly map reprojection.
If a user select a different
projection from the list, the
map will be displayed in that
particular projection as shown
on this image.
On the bottom of the page are
those WCS-based options for
customizable coverage
data sets.
The Spatial Data Access
Tool is Web-based.
It brings data visualization
and access functions from
local computers to the
worldwide web.
The emerging virtual globe
technology, like Google Earth,
uses a virtual WART on top
of the worldwide web.
We can call that the
web-wide WART.
It brings users a new and a
higher level platform and many
more benefits for
geospatial data
visualization and the delivery.
We sensed this great opportunity
and used the ASCII
WMS to KML converter to prepare
a KMZ file for each
data set for users
to visualize the
data in Google Earth.
Following the visualize in
Google Earth links, users can
access to those KMZ files from
the Spatial Data Access Tool
all the maps and corresponding
legend images displayed in
Google Earth's dynamically
created at
the ORNL WMS server.
A new map will be reshaped and
displayed in Google Earth
every time the user
touches the globe.
In the next couple of slides,
I will introduce those
benefits that users can get
from using Google Earth.
Google Earth provides rich and
valuable background maps, such
as high resolution satellite
images, roads,
landmarks, and borders.
The value of scientific data
increases the more you can
link it to information that the
user is already familiar
with and can see their
importance.
So we should take this
opportunity to present our
geospatial data in a way that
users can easily tie to other
data sources.
For example, on this screen, we
overlay the national land
coverage data, which is
available through the Spatial
Data Access Tool, with those
rich information provide
within Google Earth around
the Bay area.
The red color represents the
developed urban area.
And the brown color, which is
near the top right corner of
this image, represents
the crop lands.
So in this manner, users can
easily have a sense of those
different land types that
run on the Bay area.
Google Earth also provides
powerful address and
keywords-based locating
capability.
Say what if the user want to
see a data near Yosemite?
It is easy to locate the
Yosemite National Park within
Google Earth.
And Google Earth provides
excellent data visualization
capability.
It is globe-based and simulates
the real Earth.
Users can visualize the data
from arbitrary angle of view.
It can even virtually fly
within Google Earth.
It supports three-dimensional
objects and a
terrain surface elevation.
And this image shows how the
Google Earth overlays the
national land cover data onto
the terrain base in the
Yosemite National Park.
Within Google Earth, users can
overlay any map from any data
set for inter-comparison.
Let's compare the land cover
patterns in the Three Gorges
Dam area in China between
2001 and 2007.
The Three Gorges Dam, as marked
by the red balloon on
this image, is the world's
largest hydroelectric dam.
The first map shows the land
cover map for 2001.
And the second image shows the
land cover map for 2007.
By comparing those two images,
we can see the increase of
water area and the reduce
of crop lands.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
savannas were
replaced by mixed forests.
From those changes, we can think
that the Three Gorges
Dam does have impact
on the environment.
And there was residency
relocation activity.
One may not be able to do
accurate analysis within
Google Earth.
But a good visualization tool
like Google Earth is critical
for the generating of scientific
hypothesis and
questions that one can
go on to test.
It is part of getting
an intuitive
grasp of the problem.
It is super convenient to run
time-series animation within
Google Earth.
And this video shows the monthly
one degree resolution
CO2 flux from 1998 to 2006
displayed within Google Earth.
And this data was simulated by
the simple biosphere model
version three.
Negative values, as denoted by
the blue colors, represent
carbon uptake into
the ecosystem.
And the positive values, as
denoted by the red colors,
represent the carbon released
from the ecosystem.
You can see the blue color
region moves to the north
during summer and moves to the
south during winter, which is
a reflection of the seasonal
cycle of the CO2 flux.
Since version 5, the information
window of Google
Earth supports JavaScript
and iFrame.
This means we can put rich and
well-formatted descriptive
information about the data
layer into Google Earth.
We can even embed the Spatial
Data Access Tool inside Google
Earth so that users can
visualize the data in Google
Earth and access the data
through the Spatial Data
Access Tool without leaving
Google Earth.
And this video shows how users
can launch and use the Spatial
Data Access Tool from
within Google Earth.
From the information window,
users can see the rich,
file-level metadata
information.
You can preview the map of the
data and use some tools to
select an area and zoom into
that particular area.
You can use some other tools to
select a region for spatial
subsetting and then go ahead
to change the spatial
resolution or manually set the
region for spatial subsetting.
You can do something else, like
select a particular data
format from a list of all
available data formats and
then go ahead to access
this customized data.
This integration of Spatial Data
Access Tool and Google
Earth provides users more
convenience for the data
visualization and access.
And here comes the summary
and future work.
The ORNL DAAC and MAST-DC
are rich sources for
biogeochemical and ecological
data useful in
environmental research.
The ORNL OGC servers and the
Spatial Data Access Tool
provide efficient and
customizable visualization and
access to geospatial data
in a standard way.
Google Earth serves as a new
platform and brings many more
benefits for geospatial data
visualization and delivery.
I hope the ORNL OGC servers,
especially with access to
Google Earth, provides positive
answers to those
questions I raised before
this presentation.
In the future, we are going
to incorporate more OGC
standards, such as the Web
Feature Service, WFS, which
enables the customizable
access to
geospatial feature data.
Thank you.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]